bueno usted tiene una hija adolescente
trans verdad cuéntenos cómo ha sido el
proceso de acompañarla para que pueda
vivir libremente su identidad de género
correcto tengo una hija trans de
adolescente ya tiene 17 años sin embargo
desde los 13 empezamos con este
acompañamiento y han derivado a esto
empezamos a buscar ayuda encontrando con
esta una red de apoyo que se llama red
de familias trans en la cual él coordinó
ahora junto con otras más que me apoyen
y eso nos ha permitido tener una una
mente más abierta hacia estas
situaciones que no son tan comunes sin
embargo que son más visibles cada día y
el día de hoy es muy importante hablar
de este tema y no olvidarlo y también
para exigir sobre los derechos que
tienen también las infancias y
adolescencias para verse reconocidas
como personas trans muy personas
nominales ahora las personas trans no
binarias sufren diferentes tipos de
violencia de discriminaciones pero
quisiera preguntarle a usted qué
obstáculos en particular sufren las
infancias y las adolescencias trans
principalmente en la discriminación
empieza desde la escuela que es donde
vemos la mayor problemática cuando ellas
salen y expresan su identidad muchas
escuelas no comprenden y no son no saben
cómo manejar a estas situaciones y es
cuando se empieza a tener discriminación
hacia ellos desde que no les permiten
usar el baño con el cual se identifican
no les respetan los nombres que están
pidiendo que se les llamen quieren
cambiar su nombre quieren usar el
uniforme con el cual se identifican y
también que le sigan llamando el nombre
con el cual a unos les dio de nacimiento
muchas veces les crea mucho muchas
situaciones y eso es eso es una parte
que mucha gente no comprende que es es
violento y no respetan estas situaciones
que se dan no es muy importante escuchar
a las infancias el que sean niñas o
adolescentes no quiere decir que no
importa lo que digan aunque no tienen un
3 un desarrollo completo para saber
quiénes son la identidad es algo que
nadie te puede exponer y es es complejo
que las personas adultas nos cuesta
trabajo comprender cuando se presentan
estas situaciones sin embargo debemos
informarnos y permitir a las familias
acercarse a explicar a otros padres y
madres de familias de la escuela para
que comprendan porque eso es lo que
mayormente nos encontramos que otras
familias de las escuelas son las que
rechazan cuando hay una persona trans
este desde la primera infancia ahora no
todas las infancias y adolescencias
trans tienen la suerte de tener
familiares a una madre como usted que la
acompañe en este proceso muchas familias
los rechazan incluso las expulsa no de
sus hogares brevemente nos queda poco
tiempo pero qué mensaje tiene usted para
estas personas y para las personas trans
víctimas de bueno de la violencia dentro
de sus propios hogares
sin llegar a las personas trans yo les
digo que ya no están solas que cada vez
sabemos más y más familias que le estaba
mostrando a las familias cuando se les
presenta esta situación busquen apoyo
informen si hemos crecido en un sistema
novenario por mucho tiempo
pero no no lo sabíamos no lo sabemos
hasta que nos presentan esta situación
acércate aprende respeta escucha una
escucha radical escucha con amor es algo
que yo